hello hi good evening everyone thank you
for joining us here at politics and
prose for our Monday evening event
before we get started just a few quick
things one please take a moment now to
silence your cell phones or pagers if
anyone uses those still or anything that
could possibly make it and during our
event to after her after his talk mr.
brady carlson has agreed to take
questions so if you could line up behind
this microphone and speak clearly into
the microphone because we do have c-span
filming today so just make sure that
both the audience can hear and that it
can be recorded for posterity
third after the event if you could help
us out by folding up the chairs and just
kind of stacking them blinging them
against the side so that'd be great so
yeah I don't know how you heard about us
but politics and prose we try to be more
than a bookstore also a community center
we hold about 500 events a year between
this location on Connecticut Avenue and
our 3 Busboys and poets locations at
Tacoma 14th and V and 15 case so yeah we
have a little Flyers at the info desk
they're also online if you want to check
us out and our recording will be both on
our slate podcast and that will be on
our YouTube channel in a couple weeks so
today I have the pleasure of introducing
mr. Brady Carlson and his debut book
dead presidents which is a book about
pretty much what it sounds like
mr. Brady Carlson recounts his quest to
visit as many presidential grave sites
as possible Chris costing the country
from Massachusetts to California his day
job is a reporter and host at New
Hampshire Public Radio and his radio
host talent for sly humor and economy of
words shines through in this book it's a
whole lot of fun to read being part
first-person travelogue and part history
book and at times it almost feels like
you're flying over hundreds of miles and
across hundreds of years
face to face with the living ghosts of
presidents what I mean to say is that
this book is really good and you should
all buy it and read it but I'll let
Brady
take it away well thank you all so much
for coming I don't know if I could
really add to that I may just wanted to
sit back down thank you Jason that was
that was great no it is really wonderful
to be here with you at politics and
prose which is a dream come true to be
here I got to say thank you for the nice
weather this is fantastic I really
appreciate that it's been almost exactly
four years since I dreamed this up as a
project and so getting to share it with
all of you now after all this time is
really exciting and it's also to be
frank relief there's a period of time I
don't know how much you know about book
publishing but there's a period of time
where your manuscript is essentially
locked down no matter what happens in
the world it can't be changed until the
book comes out and then you hopefully
get to publish a second edition and we
have two presidents who are in their
90's right now and in that period where
essentially my manuscript was on the
dark side of the Moon
I lost a lot of sleep I'm not sure which
thing worried me the most the
announcement when Jimmy Carter said that
he had brain cancer or when George HW
Bush decided to celebrate his 90th
birthday by going skydiving
it was pretty harrying for me I actually
had somebody once say something to the
effect of low you know maybe your book
could come out and then something could
happen to one of them and then that's
like the extra chapter for your
paperback edition which is like that's
incredibly morbid if you think about it
and Wow I mean I got to be honest
despite the evidence that I spent four
years traveling to all the grave sites
of the u.s. Presidents I'm not a morbid
guy this was for me initially just a
chance to go to see the President to get
as close to them as you can until we
figure out a way to go back in time and
meet them in person anyway I just always
wanted to be around the president's it's
a topic that has
been interesting to me since I was a kid
I would take these stacks of books home
from the library and I would study up on
the statistics about the presidents the
way that a baseball fan might look up
you know the ER a for their favorite
pitcher or the home run and RBI totals
for their favorite cleanup hitter it's
just something that I found really
interesting but the more time that I
spent at these sites the more I realized
that there are these connections not
just about the lives of the presidents
but about their after lives for example
there's a great quote from Bill Clinton
who once said that being president is a
lot like running a cemetery there are
lots of people under you and none of
them are listening so about four years
ago I decided to make this project and I
said I'll have a look at each of these
39 grave sites there are actually 38
grave sites of US presidents but Grover
Cleveland was president on two
non-consecutive occasions so I had to
visit his grave on two non-consecutive
occasions and I realized that the more
like I said the more time that I spent
at these sites the president's never
really quite leave us they die they are
buried or they are entombed and they
have funerals but they have to keep
working and so I gave this period of
their lives or after lives a name it's
the post post presidency and it's a very
very busy time even though they're not
around to be part of it because of what
we do in their honor and in their names
I mean we are in one of the most obvious
examples of that Washington DC we just
had President's Day earlier this month
so there are a lot of really obvious
things our money has presidents all over
it but there are a lot of less obvious
examples too a lot of connections that
maybe don't come up in our wallets or in
our address mailing addresses our
highway system is officially named
Dwight D Eisenhower system of interstate
and defense highways and there's that
statue in Alexandria Virginia as the
sort of ceremonial start to the federal
highway system the man who wrote the
song this land is your land is Woodrow
Wilson Guthrie my favorite blues singer
Howlin wolf his birth name is Chester
Arthur Burnett there's a baseball
pitcher named Grover Cleveland Alexander
interesting
the one person who always comes to mind
is a famous person who was named for a
President George Washington Carver was
not actually named for George Washington
just kind of a neat fact there are these
serious connections and then there are
ones that are just plain inexplicable
and I bring you some news from the world
of Commerce there's a whole set of
presidential Pez dispensers so you can
you know open up Zachary Taylor's head
and pull out a candy which is kind of
cool and then there's the teddy bear of
course named for President Teddy
Roosevelt and then there's this one
which I will just submit without comment
this I saw in Cleveland Ohio it's from
the 19th century
Garfield T laxatives and diuretics the
slogan flush your bowels with Garfield T
but there are some some things that
connect to us even today far beyond you
know what happened 100 or 150 years ago
we saw an example of that last year when
President Obama decided to change the
name of the highest mountain in Alaska
from Mount McKinley to Denali in my home
state of New Hampshire we had an example
that about a decade ago when we have the
presidential range of mountain so
there's Mount Washington there's Mount
Adams there's now Pierce and some
lawmakers wanted to add a mount Reagan
to the presidential range there was a
big debate about that and if that I had
the same thing happened there was an
effort to put him out Reagan in Nevada
as well so these issues do come up from
time to time dead presidents can set
trends just in the same way that live
presidents can there's the old
apocryphal story about how when John F
Kennedy decided to stop wearing hats so
did the men of America that may not
actually be true but this is true after
President Kennedy died and was buried at
Arlington National Cemetery the demand
for people who wanted to be buried in
Arlington National Cemetery went up so
much that they had to tighten the
eligibility because so many people were
trying to get in that they were worried
they were going to run out of space you
will often hear the names of dead
presidents used to make points you will
hear sort of in the aftermath of
presidents death and funeral would you
know if that President were still here
today wouldn't things be different what
if we could just have a president like
that in the White House again today and
not just their names their bodies are
sometimes used to proof
two years before the civil war a
president's body was exhumed from a
northern state and moved to a southern
state partly because of the sectional
tensions another president's body was
paraded around the country just after
the Civil War essentially to convince
northerners to treat the southern states
harshly as they tried to rejoin the
Union a third president was exhumed more
than a century after his death all
basically because of a conspiracy theory
here's a short list of some of the other
connections you might not have thought
of dead presidents show up in space
there are asteroids named for at least
five of them dead presidents show up in
sports I went to a town in Iowa that
once a year has the distinct pleasure of
hosting the National Hoover ball
championships dead presidents show up in
food there's a sandwich you can get in
upstate New York called the Millard
Fillmore the Calvin Coolidge State
Historic Site in Vermont has its own
cheese shop that was started by the
Coolidge family and the cheese is
fantastic by the way dead presidents
show up in music there's a song by they
might be giants called James Koepp Hulk
Johnny Cash and Juliana Hatfield both
sang about James a Garfield Lou Reed had
a song called the day John Kennedy died
and again coming back to Millard
Fillmore he is buried in the same
Cemetery as the superfreak himself Rick
James dead presidents also are connected
to the Star Wars universe and those of
you who have ever visited Washington
National Cathedral know this because
it's the final resting place of Woodrow
Wilson high up on the tower at
Washington National Cathedral there is a
gargoyle or technically a grotesque of
Darth Vader so you have the man who
fought the war to end all wars and the
Dark Lord at the heart of the Star Wars
all in one place which is just about as
American as it gets right here's why
it's important to know about these
things not just because they're fun or
because they're important to know about
you're paying for the world of dead
presidents because every single
president these days is entitled to a
state funeral conducted by the US
military every president is entitled to
a presidential library run by the
National Archives and Records
Administration and on each presidents
birthday the military holds a wreath
ceremony at his grave all of which we
pay for through our tax dollars now this
whole crazy world starts right in this
part of the country
and let me just start before I tell you
these stories be kind if you know some
of these stories as Washingtonians just
tell all your friends at the dead
presidents book tour after parties
tonight that you know there was this
adorable guy at the bookstore and how
cute it was that he came to DC and
ma'ams blamed us all about the
Washington Monument at upfront but this
story really does begin where all things
begin with the US presidents with George
Washington just as he set so many
precedents and customs and traditions
about how a president was to act what he
was to do and what he was not to do so
too did he become the first dead
president and create all sorts of
precedents about how we're treating our
former leaders after they pass on and in
George Washington's case it was maybe a
little bit bigger than usual because
here's someone that we couldn't even
wait until he was gone to start
memorializing him we wanted to turn him
into a legend before he was even dead
not long after the American Revolution
was over there was talk in the
governmental circles about building a
giant statue of George Washington of a
horse back in the center of the new
capital city to be a sort of large-scale
example to the nation it was supposed to
look if you've ever been to Washington
Circle that statue of George Washington
horse back was supposed to be like that
but like Voltron sized or transformer
size so and George Washington was very
very nervous when he heard this kind of
talk because he remembered a time when
he was in New York City and his soldiers
have heard the declaration of
independence for the first time and they
reacted so strongly that they went up to
a statue of the king of England on
horseback and they tore it down he
thought if this whole democratic
experiment goes south I don't want
people like that tearing down my statue
so he pushed as hard as he could to try
and say let's build the country let's
not build statues of me thank you very
much there was one exception which was
when the three commissioners who were in
charge of designing what was then known
as the federal city decided to name it
Washington and he let them do that not
because he thought oh well I should at
least get one thing named after me but
because he had hired them to lead
construction and he didn't want to
micromanage so he let that one go though
if you look through his papers he always
refers to
this town as the federal city he doesn't
ever refer to it as Washington which is
kind of neat so in life George
Washington send it off all of these
attempts to memorialize him before he
was dead and then he died on December 14
1799 and that's when everything started
to change well it change for him first
of all for obvious reasons he had a bad
throat infection in December and his
doctors did him no favors by trying to
take something like five of his eight
pints of blood while simultaneously
trying to get him to throw up that did
not help him and nor did what happened
next see Washington was very clear in
his will about what he wanted after he
died for example one of the things he
specified was he did not want to be
buried for at least three days because
he was concerned about being buried
alive he also did not want funeral
parades he did not want riderless horses
he did not want long speeches he wanted
simple private funeral services
essentially he wanted to be left alone
here's what he said in his will I'm just
going to quote it is my expressed desire
that my corpse may be interred in a
private manner without parade or funeral
oration do you think he got a simple
private quiet funeral no we don't roll
that way in this country so he got a
lung funeral parade he wanted zero
speakers he got four at his funeral
service at Mount Vernon they were
riderless horses and there were rumors
that the country was short on black
cloth four months after were the
services because there was so much
mourning going on for those who couldn't
be at the actual funeral at Mount Vernon
they held mock funerals across many of
the cities in the country my favorite is
the story about what they did in Boston
where they not only had a mock funeral
but they struck commemorative coins to
cut to remember the mock funeral that
said something like the world is in
tears but he is in glory and this may
sound a little over the top even by our
usual standards but remember this is at
a time when the United States of America
is still very young and maybe not that
United for a lot of people the thing
that was holding the country together
and keeping it from splitting further
and further apart was the force of
personality that was George Washington
and they were scared that now that
George Washington was dead they might
start to lose that force of personality
that was binding them together they came
up with a kind of a cool solution if
George Washington was a mortal man you
lose him but if he was more than a man
you can't possibly lose him because he
will always be with you and so if you
visit the US Capitol and you look up and
inside the rotunda on the inside of the
dome you see one of the great examples
of that that painting called the
apotheosis of Washington it's a pain
it's a portrait of George Washington
being welcomed into heaven as a demigod
by a group of angels and this was not
simply just over the top memorializing
they were really trying to hang on to
this guy as long as they could this is
also about the time that you start to
hear stories like the biography from
parson Weems where George Washington
could not tell a lie that he chopped
down the cherry tree these legends and
tales of how perfect George Washington
was as a person he became a sort of
civic deity because they just wanted to
keep him as long as they could the only
problem was is that they always they
weren't always so good at honoring him
the best example of that can be found
today at the Smithsonian Museum of
American history
there's a sculpture by Horatio Green now
who was by all accounts a very good
sculptor he trained in Italy he knew his
stuff Congress gave him I think $20,000
to make a massive sculpture in George
Washington's honor and it sounded like a
good concept he was trying to tie George
Washington to the Greek and Roman
leaders of old so someone who is granted
huge amounts of power uses that power
responsibly and then voluntarily hands
it back without any attempt to keep it
beyond his mandate and that was the idea
anyway what he actually ended up
creating was a George Washington in a
toga and he's holding a sword out it's
supposed to symbolize how he was handing
the sword of power back to the people
what it looks like is a guy who just
left a frat party trying to stab himself
and it was literally laughed out of the
Capitol Rotunda they put it outside on
the Capitol grounds at which point
people would snicker about how it look
like George Washington is leaving a
bathhouse and reaching for his robe so
they had to keep moving it from place to
place and it was it was moved into the
Smithsonian at one point and they have
it now it is definitely worth seeing if
you haven't seen it now at the same time
that all of this is going on there's
talk about we should have George
Washington's actual remains at the US
Capitol I mean people can come to the
Capitol they can look up at the Rotonda
and see this great painting but they can
also look down and see the sarcophagus
that holds George Washington's remains
there's only one problem with that they
didn't check with the family when they
came to pick the body up someone said
did you look at the will and the will
again said I would like to be left at
Mount Vernon and basically left alone so
they had to plug the hole that they had
carved into the Capitol Rotunda floor
where you're going to look down they'd
to plug that up and if you go start your
tour of the US Capitol today you will
start at a room called the crypt that
was supposed to hold George Washington
now it just holds lots of tour groups
and all while all of that was going on
there was another group of prominent
citizens including Chief Justice John
Marshall and former President James
Madison who thought we need to build a
monument not just a monument but a great
monument a huge monument the best
monument as designed the original plan
for the Washington Monument would have
been the tallest structure in the world
the problem here was that they couldn't
get the supplies of marble nor the money
to pay for said marble together in any
kind of organized fashion so they would
build a little bit here and there and
then they would have to stop and raise
more money then they would build a
little bit more they have to stop raise
more money for years and years and years
the Washington Monument was a big stump
in the middle of the capitol city where
you saw not the greatness of George
Washington reflected and I in ideas and
symbols but you saw literal cows pigs
and sheep grazing at the foot of this
unfinished marble thing there's a great
article I think in the New York Times at
the time in the middle of the 19th
century that said something like the
portrait of George Washington can in the
White House can see that the stump as it
sits in the middle of the city and you
can almost see a tear in its eye forming
is just a beautiful thing in July 1850
they held a fundraiser to try and
kick-start things yet again and the
guest of honor at this fundraiser was
the sitting president Zachary Taylor it
was a very hot day so president Taylor
decided to cool off by eating hot
cherries and drinking iced milk
health officials had warned people not
to consume those things because there
were diseases roaming around the city
less than a week later he was dead so in
other words we tried to honor one dead
president and ended up creating another
and now if you've ever been to the
Washington Monument you know that spot
where the color changes in the marble
that's where the stump era ended and the
US Army Corps of Engineers era began
because after a while they realized
there was only one organization in the
world that could finally finish this
thing off they handed it to the US Army
Corps of Engineers they got her done
although it did take until 1885 which
was more than a century after the idea
for a monument in the central part of
Washington DC was first proposed 86
years after George Washington died and
there had been 20 presidents after
George Washington that's how long it
took and even today it still lines up
being under repair you remember the
earthquake about five years ago there's
extensive renovation after that and this
is a city that hosts a lot of tour
groups many of which consist of
eighth-grade boys who will look at
something that looks like the Washington
Monument in a way that is just unseemly
to our eyes and they will take horrible
pictures and say terrible things and
snicker to each other over them which is
just awful so that's the story of George
Washington the national myth I haven't
even gotten to the body really yet I
mentioned he wanted to stay at Mount
Vernon in his will he asked could you
please at least move my remains out of
the old family tomb and put them in a
new one because the old tomb is situated
right by the Potomac River which was
prone to flooding so he was worried that
his bones were going to wind up washing
downstream it took about 30 years to
build that tomb because Mount Vernon was
unprofitable it was a huge plantation
there are all these people who were
making essentially pilgrimages to Mount
Vernon uninvited
and so by the time that they did finally
build this new tomb
Washington's remains not as remains but
what was holding them the coffin was
deteriorating and so the the guys who
took charge of moving George
Washington's remains from the old casket
to the new sarcophagus are great they
wrote up an account for this for a
magazine of the day and everything that
they wrote about that was in passive
voice so no one picked him up and moved
him he was moved somehow and in the
process of moving him somehow a hand was
laid upon his head and a hair was taken
from his head whose hand padded them.we
well I couldn't have been us we didn't
do it someone did it and someone took
his head I don't know who did these
things nonetheless they managed to make
a successful transfer with one caveat
that the new tomb was too small to fit
the sarcophagus they apparently not
measured so they had to put it in front
of the new tomb and then build around it
and somewhere along the line someone
clipped off part of the Eagle design on
top of the sarcophagus as a souvenir but
just like with the Washington Monument
and just like with the US Capitol and
just like with everything involved with
memorializing George Washington they got
it all figured out over time they ironed
the wrinkles out of the system I mean
Mount hua Mount Vernon has had something
like 80 million visitors over time
including presidents and queens and
kings and all sorts of dignitaries and
things run in shipshape over there you
can take a house tour you can see what
it was like living George Washington's
time you can sample some of the whisky
that was that was distilled using his
actual recipe there even to the point
now where if you know those national
treasure movies you can go take a
Nicholas Cage tour of George
Washington's house which is just
fascinating but you can also take a
wreath you can also take part in a
wreath ceremony that they have twice a
day at Mount Vernon if you do that and I
highly advise you to because it's really
cool listen closely for the tomb because
I'm pretty sure you can hear the sound
of George Washington rolling over in his
grave but all of the things we have done
to him
over the years now I said before that
Washington set precedence with his death
so what is it that what are the customs
that have come up thanks to George
Washington in the world of dead
presidents
well first we go big when it comes to
presidents whether they want that or not
we make large expensive monuments that
take forever and we argue about them for
a long long time we open a lot of
coffins we've moved a lot of presidents
bodies we've moved a lot of presidents
bodies
there's thievery there's all kinds of
bad behavior but we tend to get it all
right in the end though I will say that
if you look at the timeline of dead
presidents George Washington dies in
1799 and there is not another dead
president until 1826 and I have a theory
that John Adams and Thomas Jefferson the
immediate successors to George
Washington were convinced having seen
what had happened to their predecessor
that they wanted to avoid becoming dead
presidents as long as possible so I will
just say thank you all so much for
coming it is such a treat to be here
with you in Washington and I would be
happy to take any questions that you
have about any of the dead presidents or
all of them if you prefer but thank you
all again so much for coming
[Applause]
well that's light at the other end oh
the other story to tell us about the
amazing beautiful series kind of semi
circles of columns that marks the demise
of warren g harding oh my first warren g
harding question this is fantastic does
everybody remember that warren g harding
was in fact a president of the united
states okay good
he's one of those guys who's just sort
of on the list you know sort of like at
the end of the Gilligan's Island songs
like and there's ginger and Mary Ann
he's Warren Harding it's like the Mary
Ann of the presidents anyway Warren
Harding has I think one of the most
beautiful tombs it is a circular set of
columns is absolutely gorgeous it's in
Marion Ohio which is a small town and
it's funny because Warren Harding died
in 1923 and it took I didn't get to
write a whole lot about this in the book
but it took a long time to raise the
money to put those columns up because
after Harding died we started to learn a
little bit more about what had been
going on in his white house the drinking
the gambling the fathering of children
with someone who was not his wife
the carousing of all hours and the
Teapot Dome scandal which was at that
point the worst possible thing that any
president had been involved in and so
the long the more of these revelations
that came out in the wake of Harding's
death the less people wanted to give to
make a giant memorial and his honor in
his hometown of Marion Ohio so Calvin
Coolidge his successor his one-time vice
president does some fundraising and then
that sort of tapers off and then the
next president Herbert Hoover's quietly
cancels some of the events that he was
going to do on behalf of the Harding
Memorial Association and so it takes a
long long time they do finally get it
built and then there was an article in
Life magazine in the 1940s which is you
know he'd barely gone and the memorial
was almost still brand new and I
remember the caption underneath the
picture they had done a photo survey of
all of the grave sites and it says at
the bottom of the Harding Memorial not
many people go there now like it had
been sitting there for decades and it
just become
been forgotten it was brand-new and
they'd already kind of ignored him I am
happy to report that when I was in
Marion Ohio visiting Warren G Harding's
grave that they have found a new use for
that beautiful monument that is where
all the kids who go to high school in
Marion Ohio take their prom pictures
from the looks of things they all know I
mean it's this most scenic spot that
they could find and so so that I just
stopped by to take a few pictures and I
see this limo pull up with these you
know 17 year olds in in their finest
outfits and then they stop and they pose
and they wave and they hug and then they
go off the prom and I'm left there just
me and warren g harding yes great great
talk great stories so overall do you
know - sort of percentage-wise or
comparison how many presidents have very
quiet little gravestones or grave sites
and how many are kind of grand and
memorial style and how many wanted I
mean does that match their desires
that's that's a great question I don't
know if I know the percentages but there
are quite a few that have pretty
relatively small tombs a few that might
surprise you would be Theodore Roosevelt
on Long Island that's a pretty small
quiet private spot and Lyndon Johnson
who you'd expect to have just an
enormous Texas sized tomb has just
another stone and the family plot I
guess for Johnson what he wanted instead
was to have a gigantic presidential
library which he did get this there's an
interview I read once with the architect
of the Johnson library in Austin Texas
on the University campus and they said
you know describe why it's so big why is
it ten stories high just this towering
thing and he said well President Johnson
wanted to have a really manly virile
Presidential Library by God that's what
he got but his tomb is the exact
opposite he just wanted to be buried in
you know in his family spot with next to
the Peter and Alice Rivlin quiet
it adds inflows they're some of the
earliest presidents the you know the
Washington's the atoms is the
Jefferson's they have very nice and
somewhat ornate final resting places but
they're private and and that used to be
model that you know presidents would
pass away home or they would you know as
private citizen that did not any longer
belong to the country and so their final
resting places would reflect that it
changes in two big ways one is during
the Victorian era just because death
became not just a fact of life but an
aesthetic so the idea of a really big
tomb became much more prevalent
especially with the assassinated
presidents grant's tomb is the biggest
in technical size just in the dimensions
it's the largest but William McKinley's
to me feels bigger it looks like a
planetarium is on at the top of this
hill so it's you know it's the kind of
thing that you know if you were seeking
a Jedi you would go up this this hill
and head and go there and James a
Garfield in Cleveland Ohio who died
right at the height of the Victorian era
in 1881 he has and I am not making this
up
he has a deaf castle it is a gigantic
castle and on the outside of it there
are reliefs of the different stages of
his life from his time as an educator in
rural Ohio to his service in the Civil
War to his service in the government to
laying in on his deathbed in agony
because of incompetent doctors they
actually made a point of putting that up
there of showing James a Garfield in
agony for half of his short presidency
and on the inside and this is the worst
thing I think I saw although a worst is
relative I think it's kind of awesome
but it's I don't know that how many
people would want this there's a mural
of the assassination inside Garfield's
tomb you know so there's there's this
picture of Garfield sort of walking
through the train station in DC and the
Secretary of State is walking with him
and he knows what's about to go down
he's frantically waving his arms like
look out sir look out and Garfield
doesn't see it in the train attendants
is there and he's like look ah no and
Garfield doesn't see it sort of you know
you just you look on this thing and each
James a Garfield what did he ever do to
anybody to deserve all of this this
indignity that has been thrust upon him
I visited there the week after that I
spent some time in the Los Angeles area
visiting the graves of presidents Nixon
and Reagan and I'm sitting on a plane
come back to New Hampshire and I'm
getting these emails from all over the
did you hear what happened at Garfield's
to him they're like what now it turns
out someone had gotten drunk broke into
Garfield's tomb and stolen some of the
commemorative spoons that were on
display in the case there and he do it's
just like you know we had reached peak
Garfield in big duty tomb here it was
just the worst possible thing to someone
who has you know he had a really if he
had known what was coming he would have
turned the nomination down I'm convinced
of that any other questions just refresh
me just for refresh me is Jefferson's
actual burial place in Monticello
Jefferson's burial place is and
Monticello the interesting piece about
that is that Monticello the property is
run by a non-profit foundation except
for the family burial ground which is
still controlled now by the descendants
of Jefferson's of Jefferson's
descendants and the reason that that
matters is because they're a group of
people who say we are descendants of
Thomas Jefferson by way of Sally Hemings
one of the enslaved people who lived at
the plantation and they are not
officially recognized by the family even
though they are officially recognized by
Monticello so you have a disagreement at
this property about who is part of the
Jefferson family because the Jefferson
the official Jefferson family still does
not recognize the Hemings descendants
they are not eligible to be buried in
that family plot and every so often you
will hear of an effort to to bring that
group into the fold so to speak so this
is one more example of how these issues
come back up even something that
happened hundreds and hundreds of years
ago still matters today great question
though
there are Coolidge's in the Jefferson
cemetery I I didn't I didn't look
closely enough to be sure that's
certainly possible I'll look for the
tell-tale signs of cheese when I go back
you mentioned Zachary Taylor and the
cherries and milk are there any other
strange causes of death for presidents
any other strange causes of death for
presidents um well legend has it well
other than Garfield yeah who whose
doctors did more damage to him than the
bullets ever did the legends have it did
William Henry Harrison died because he
stood out in the cold during his
inaugural address without a hat and a
coat and spoke for two hours now I have
read his entire inaugural address and it
didn't kill me but it certainly did put
me to sleep
it was it was it is still the record
longest inaugural address and it is a
long even even for that number of words
it goes by very slowly it's a lot of
talk about the pros and cons of using
the veto power and a number of
references when he's done sort of
charting a course back through you know
the short at that point tale of American
history then goes back into Roman
history and apparently Daniel Webster
who is you know from my home state of
New Hampshire managed to cut about half
of the Pro consuls that William Henry
Harrison wanted to mention in his
address out but it was still wasn't
enough it there's actually been some
research in recent years that says
people should probably more look at the
water system of Washington DC at the
time that there are three presidents
Taylor Polk and Harrison who died in
about a ten year period and it could
very easily all be attributed to the
terrible conditions of the water and
sewer system in Washington DC at that
time but you know even knowing that
there are still people who talk about
William Henry Harrison to their kids is
like this is why you put a coat on when
you go outside in the winter do you want
to end up like that guy yeah although I
did realize one time I was out in Dallas
it was the 50th anniversary of the
Kennedy assassination and so before they
were having their formal commemorative
ceremony they were showing clips of his
inaugural address and I figured how cold
could it possibly get in Texas well
apparently you can get really cold in
Texas
so I was wearing not nearly enough in
terms of coats hats and gloves I was
freezing and I was sitting outside
listening to an inaugural address in the
video screen I'm like I turned into
William Henry Harrison what's going to
happen to me in 30 days it was not a
good feeling anyway this is related and
perhaps you've already answered it what
about the rumors of Warren Harding being
poisoned and a second question when was
the first job president seems to be a
tradition of presidential libraries now
when did that start with Johnson nor was
our offer or when did that start
well the the rumors of Warren Harding
being poisoned we actually have a
tradition of assuming that every
president who dies during office was
done in by some nefarious means and it
goes back to William Henry Harrison
someone tried to murder him because of
slavery someone murdered Zachary Taylor
because of slavery that's why he was
exhumed in the 1990s by the way he died
in 1850 and they brought him back out in
1991 just to check on what had killed
him this story of Warren Harding this is
this was one of the the best-selling
books that came out after he died that
suggested that his wife had found out
about all of his extramarital dalliance
'iz and had poisoned him and that was a
best-selling book it was almost
certainly just rumors
trying to get book sales wish I'd
thought of that and but but the public
ate it up as if it were real and also
some of the Harding papers were burned
by his widow which did not help the case
of the people who were saying that this
is all hogwash so those have persisted
certainly over the years there were
supposedly there were people even after
Franklin Roosevelt died who said well
you know he's there there are so many
great different stories about what had
actually happened to Franklin Roosevelt
some had said that you know the Soviets
had killed him other people said it was
an inside job and some people said that
actually Franklin Roosevelt faked his
death and was actually living out in
upstate New York very happily he just
didn't want to be president anymore
after twelve and a half years so these
these stories do apparently seem to crop
up now as to the presidential
libraries that the first public
presidential library came from Franklin
Roosevelt he proposed the idea of a
taxpayer-funded Presidential Library
while he was still president which again
going back to this model where the
president is a private citizen who has
great power for a short period of time
and then returns to being a private
citizen that idea was well we'll just
say it's a little controversial in the
1940s when he proposes it it was partly
I think for Roosevelt the public works
project it was another idea to make some
jobs it was also a way for him to deal
with he was kind of a hoarder and he
would he wanted a place where he could
store all this stuff but he didn't want
to just put it in the National Archives
and part of that is because presidents
tend to have egos and they want to be
remembered and they want to be
remembered fondly in a way that they
would like to be remembered and so that
all of that went into the Presidential
Library so they did lawmakers then did
approve a Presidential Library not only
for FDR but for every president since
and they included Herbert Hoover who was
still alive at the time so he has a
taxpayer-funded Presidential Library
this is the big change in how presidents
are memorialized because more or less up
until that point presidents sort of left
it to us to make all of the decisions
and we would shape their legacies more
than they would that means some of them
would write memoirs or make speeches and
sort of put their hand out there and try
and characterize their own works but now
they have a partly taxpayer-funded
Presidential Library to put their own
part of the message out there and give
their perspective and and they love that
not all historians love that there are a
lot of critics who say that we are
underwriting presidents telling us how
we should remember them and they're not
thrilled about that what we do see at
least is that over time many of the
presidential libraries that are a couple
of generations old you'll see a lot more
balance
for example the Roosevelt Library just
went under a large renovation and you
see all kinds of exhibits about the
Japanese internment and some of his
extramarital affairs and things like
that and the decision about how he
handled the war and so forth
so you do see these things change over
time but I get to say the best part of
the presidential libraries is not that
they have this treasure trove of
documents although they do have that and
that's one thing that historians did not
always have access to before the library
system started but because they collect
everything they throw nothing out and so
they have the weirdest stuff the
Roosevelt Library has a giant Franklin
Roosevelt head in the shape of a sphinx
the Lyndon Johnson library in Texas has
a joke-telling robot of LBJ there was a
get-well raccoon that I saw at the
Richard Nixon Library it was sent to his
sent to him just after he'd had a stroke
that killed him they thought maybe the
stuffed raccoon will pull him out of his
stroke but there's just amazing stuff
and the Nixon Library also has the
famous picture of when he met Elvis at
the White House and that's like they
have a life-sized version of that in the
gift shop so if you want to stand next
to Nixon meeting Elvis you can do that
so there's so many great things that you
can do at a Presidential Library and for
me the the weird stuff is is where I go
first but maybe that's maybe that's just
me um I I had always wanted to just
visit these sites I just thought it
would be kind of interesting I thought
it was about as close as I could get to
meeting the president in person and and
I didn't know four years ago when I just
said I'm just going to start visiting
these exactly how it was going to turn
out what happened was that through a
sort of convoluted series of emails a
stranger who thought my idea sounded
interesting contacted an agent in New
York who then contacted me who then
helped me write a proposal who we then
chopped to publishers who then got us
together with WW Norton who very kindly
let me carry out this kind of goofy
adventure so the moral of the story to
me is always have a contact form on your
website because you never know who's
going to write but what I what I did was
because they're the presidents are are
scattered throughout the country but
there are clusters there are a lot in
Ohio there are a lot in Virginia there
are quite a few in the Northeast and
there are four right here in the DC
so I would take a trip see all of the
things in one part of the country that I
could see you know over a three or
four-day period and then go back home
and and try to process what I what I had
seen do some follow up with interviews
and research and things like that and
then just corral it together other than
that it was just a lot of you know
staying up nights and weekends because I
have a day job and at that point I had
one small kid now I have three which by
the way it's amazing how much work you
can get done when you never sleep but
that was just the general idea just a
little bit here and there plugging away
and and you know and over time people
would who knew about what I was doing
would get in touch and they'd say oh did
you hear about you know these people who
collect political memorabilia maybe you
should talk to them or here's this event
that goes on each year maybe you should
stop by and just kind of unfolded like
that yes so sometimes when you're
writing you end up learning something
about your topic you know you've done
all the research already was there any
particular president that as you were
writing the text you actually began to
change your opinion about that person
yes I changed my opinion probably about
each of them because you know I because
I read all the same books that everybody
else who studied the president's read I
had pretty much the conventional
understanding of who George Washington
was and Hebron Lincoln was and who all
of these people were I would say I think
I say James a Garfield is one that
really resonated with me because he's
almost completely forgotten there was I
remember one of those kids guides to the
presidents where it would say you know
their names their party their term in
office and their notable accomplishments
and under James II Garfield's notable
accomplishments it said and this was the
only thing listed assassinated by
deranged office seeker that was his one
accomplishment which is kind of true but
how depressing is that so that book
destiny of the Republic by Candice
Maillard really I read through that
probably four or five times and she did
a great job of characterizing she's what
a neat individual he was and how much
potentially he had to be a good
president
had he lived and had it not been for the
doctors he probably would have lived if
he had lived in our time he would have
been home from the hospital in a couple
of days so that was one example more
possible a more popular well-known one
is John F Kennedy III come from a
generation who did not I don't remember
the Kennedy assassination that was
before my time I just remember my
parents telling me about what it was
like to live through that in the same
way that my grandparents told me what it
was like to live through Pearl Harbor
and how people today talked about what
it was like to have experienced the 9/11
attacks and I think if Kennedy was one
of the hardest presidents to write about
because he is so well documented and
there is so much tens of thousands of
books about John F Kennedy and what else
is there that could be said and so what
I had to do was just look at him from a
completely different angle and so I went
to the 50th anniversary commemorations
of the assassination in Dallas which
Dallas is not a place that has done a
lot of commemorating of the
assassination of John F Kennedy because
why would you write but this year they
thought all eyes are on us maybe for the
last time with the people who
experienced the assassination firsthand
still around to commemorate it and what
I found was is that the reason that it
continues to resonate with us is for a
lot of reasons but among them was
essentially good branding and I don't
want to play that crassly but the
Kennedys did a phenomenal job of
creating the idea that these are people
that matter to us in a very short period
of time when they first proposed the
idea of creating a funeral for John F
Kennedy that was modeled after Abraham
Lincoln that was not the obvious choice
they would have gone back to the last
president who had died in office
Franklin Roosevelt or Warren Harding
before him which was still a large-scale
state funeral but not with the now the
Abraham Lincoln gravitas that he ended
up getting and you could have made a
case in a pretty convincing one at that
point does this guy merit that and it
turned out that the public body did and
and that's just fascinating and a lot of
that is because
as the Kennedy family and including
Jacqueline Kennedy did a really good job
of sort of framing his presidency and
his legacy in a way that that hit home
personally for people it wasn't just
that he was a political figure or
anything like that but that he was one
of the great people of history and that
he would be a towering figure who could
not be quite equalled and and they made
a case that most presidential gravesites
don't make which is that his ideals live
on the eternal flame and no other
president has an eternal flame most of
the gravesites look backwards his does
not and that's uh that just struck me at
how how much went into that I thought
was really fascinating because it it
seems when you know when you think about
it now you think well all of this was
just a natural thing and it wasn't a
natural thing was all done on purpose
but it felt so natural and that's I
think was the true genius of everything
that went into that funeral and has gone
into all of the memorializing we've done
of John F Kennedy is that it was all
done deliberately but it all feels so
natural
not everybody can say that yes with the
story of the rivalry between two high
schools here in the district there's a
rivalry over the Washington Monument
here no rivalry between two high schools
two galvanizes drag-out and st. John's
and any Gonzaga student had the idea of
taking out two of the bowls of the four
spotlight
the colors of Gonzaga are purple and
white it's about to put in purple balls
which would have been fun he decided to
go far as Eric you minute and some
friends was up the Washington Monument
hung out from the window impale spike
into the monument and hung
well this would go Gonzaga be st. John
well if you're gonna if you're going to
go big on something like that if you
really want to stick it to st. John's I
mean you know you know you're not you're
not going to go over the James Buchanan
Memorial are you but isn't it funny how
these things they all have their there
they're these connotations that build up
over time you know there's all of a
sudden well Washington Monument you know
which was built for one big huge purpose
winds up being part of the high school
rivalry between Gonzaga and st. John's
that's so that's fantastic last question
I just wanted to add a little bit about
Kennedy's funeral there's a big Irish
festival coming up with a Kennedy Center
this may be a hundred years of Kennedy's
birth next year and 100 years of the
Easter Rising this year but he
apparently stayed in touch from a number
of the people over in Ireland after he
took the trip there only four months
before he died and a number of them
announced almost immediately that they
would be coming to Washington and when
de Gaulle the French president felt that
he had to do something good for Jackie
that kind of sealed the deal but it
would be a grand event yeah yeah they
and and and again I don't want to make
this sound crass but they made it so
that it was something I don't want to
call it tv-friendly but they made it
something that people who were watching
on TV could feel personally invested
into which is is fascinating I mean even
the things the the fascinating part
about the Kennedy funeral for me is that
even the things that went wrong went
right so for example there's the the
famous playing of taps where one of the
I think of one of the fifth or sixth
note cracks that the bugler didn't quite
land the note and they're all these
commenters who said well you know it was
like mirroring the nation's grief
because it was like when somebody you
know gives a speech or sings a song and
they start to lose their composure
that's what it sounded like
or the riderless horse was kind of out
of control blackjack was his name and
they said well this horse is clearly
just so wound up because he feels how
horrible everybody feels I'll end on a
happier note which is weird given what
this book is about but there
quite a few of these stories about
animals blackjack is a great example of
that from the Kennedy funeral but my
favorite comes back we'll come back to
warren g harding at the end where we
started with our questions when warren g
harding died he was best known perhaps
at the time for having the first
celebrity presidential dog laddie boy
and when Warren Harding died these
newspaper articles tell me if this is
not the saddest thing that you could
think of it regards to a presidential
death there are all these newspaper
articles about there was one member of
the White House contingent that couldn't
understand why the president's car
wasn't driving him back up to pet him
and give him doctrine for laddie boy
could not understand where presidents
President Harding was and why he wasn't
coming back to the White House so
someone who heard about this horrible
situation with the dog wrote a song
trying to explain to the president's dog
what had happened it was called laddie
boy he's gone and it talks about you
know he's president in heaven now laddie
boy you just have to understand so you
know presidential grief and monuments
and memorializing goes even to into the
world of pets which is just again so
beautiful and so American this we
connect these things in every possible
way and bless us for it and on that I
just say bless all of you for coming out
thank you again this is so great there's
a piece of the pulse today about several
of the horses of Fort Myer games retired
oh yeah well if anyone would like this
book signed if you could start here
inform if you go in that length you know
oh thank you